JULIE WISKIRCHEN: Hello,
everybody.
I'm Julie Wiskirchen from the
Authors@Google team in Los Angeles.
And today, we're excited to
welcome Brant Cooper and
Patrick Vlaskovits.
And they're going to be
discussing their new book,
"The Lean Entrepreneur."
Brant Cooper travels the world
speaking to entrepreneurs and
consulting and advising
startups.
His clients include Qualcomm,
MOGL, HubKick, MotherKnows,
i.TV, Lean Startup Machine,
Discovr, and many others.
He has over 20 years experience
in IT and a long
track record of bringing high
tech products to market.
Patrick Vlaskovits is an
entrepreneur, mentor, and author.
He's founded two startups,
serves as CMO at Drumbi, and
co-wrote "The Entrepreneur's
Guide to Customer
Development--
A Cheat Sheet to The Four
Steps to the Epiphany."
Patrick has spoken at tech
conferences nationally and
internationally and serves as a
mentor for the 500 Startups
and for The Lean Startup
Machine.
So please join me in welcoming
Brant and Patrick.
[APPLAUSE]
BRANT COOPER: Thanks
for having us here.
It's great to be here.
We want to make this really
super interactive.
We've got a presentation around
the challenges of doing
lean startup type stuff inside
of large successful
organizations.
So I'm not sure we've been
to a large successful
organization that's also
traditionally very innovative
like Google.
So we'd love to actually have a
discussion about some of the
things that you're seeing inside
of Google-- what's
working, what's maybe
not working.
Here's our book.
You all get a copy, I believe.
So what's sort of the backdrop
of this stuff?
Do you want to kick this off?
PATRICK VLASKOVITS: Sure, so the
fundamental premise behind
the book, and why we think the
book is important and timely
right now, is that there is
a fundamental shift change
happening in our economy,
and probably globally.
You've probably heard the
expression by Marc Andreessen,
the venture capitalist--
software is eating the world.
We buy into this or subscribe to
this vision and this idea.
And what this means is
big things, right?
So I actually think we're
in this sort of perma
non-economic recovery.
We're seeing technological
unemployment, big problems,
the middle class is being
hollowed out.
Personally, I don't think either
side of the political
aisle knows what's
really going on.
It is a big problem, right?
We're all feeling that
traditional economic solutions
don't seem to be working.
And this is the state
of the economy.
This is one reason why you're
seeing this explosion of
startups, right?
You didn't see articles about
startups in the "Wall Street
Journal" every day.
And the other day my wife asked
me, has the "Wall Street
Journal" always been writing
about startups?
Five years ago, they weren't.
Yeah, once in a while
they'd mention it,
et cetera, et cetera.
But now, this explosion of
startups is sort of a response
to this really screwed
up economy that we
happen to be in.
BRANT COOPER: And it's
global as well.
So we're lucky enough to travel
the world and talk to
people that are graduating from
schools in Kuala Lumpur,
Malaysia, and Ireland,
and Spain.
And all of these people are
assuming that what they're
going to do is start
a business.
And maybe it's because
it's the only
opportunity that they have.
But that's one side
of the equation.
There's also, as you all know,
it's the global connectivity,
the fact that we're holding
computers in our pockets.
It's crowdsourcing,
it's crowdfunding.
It's the idea that we buy books
from software companies,
we buy movies from software
companies.
We do shopping exclusively
related to software companies.
All existing product companies
also have software throughout
their company, right?
So this is the software
eating the world.
It's interesting if you talk
to hardware people.
They're saying that we're at the
same stage as open source
software-- we're in the same
stage in open source hardware
as we were in the late '70s
around the time of the Apple I
or the Apple II.
And if you think about the
amount of change that went on
in the software in the last
25, 30 years, it's pretty
amazing to think about what the
next decade might bring in
terms of open source hardware.
Has anybody seen the photo
booths in Japan?
Traditionally, you'd go to
a carnival or whatever,
amusement park, and you've got
the photo booths, and you go
in there with your friends.
And you're all being all goofy
and making funny expressions.
And you get a strip of
film out, right?
In Japan, you get 3D printed
figurines with
your face on it.
There's a shoe executive at
a Forward Conference says,
within two years, you'll be able
to print out your shoes.
So you'll just be downloading a
shoe style and print it out.
A movie executive says, oh, well
you guys now are going to
figure out what software
piracy's all about.
It's actually kind of an
interesting idea, right?
The joke is on the movie
industry, if you ask me
though, because they haven't
figured out what their
business model is.
So anyway, massive amounts
of change--
wow, is this thing--
there we go.
So all sorts of volatility,
uncertainty,
opportunity, right?
So massive changes in the world
happening-- structural
changes, people wondering what
they're going to be doing,
people graduating from college
wondering what jobs they're
going to have.
We believe that this is the
right opportunity for being
fast, agile, and being close
to your customer.
We think we're moving away
from an economy that's
concentrating on purely wealth
creation and going towards
value creation.
And so that the winners are
the people that understand
their customers deeply.
So why don't you give the
Scott Summit example.
PATRICK VLASKOVITS: Sure, so in
the book, there's actually
a few case studies, more
than two dozen.
And one of most interesting we
thought was the case study of
a guy named Scott Summit.
Scott's an industrial designer,
and he's been doing
some pretty innovative stuff
in terms of 3D printing for
prostheses.
So people come, usually amputees
missing a limb,
usually a lower limb, and they
go to Scott to get new
prosthetics.
And traditionally, what a person
in this situation would
do is they would go and get a
mass manufactured limb, often
made in Asia, sort of a
rudimentary simple pipe-type
device, right?
And they fasten it on.
And then they make sure to put
their jeans over the device,
over the prosthetic, and
go on with their lives.
BRANT COOPER: They actually will
stuff socks down in there
to actually simulate the
shape of a calf.
PATRICK VLASKOVITS: So what's
interesting about what Scott's
done, he's done, as I said
earlier, technological
innovation where he actually
uses 3D scanning technology to
actually scan the good leg,
then invert it and build a
digital model of the
missing limb.
And then use 3D printing
technology to print what he
calls a fairing that mimics the
shape and feel and weight
of the real missing limb.
And this is actually fascinating
not only because
the technology is sort of the
stuff of magic and science,
but because the actual business
model innovation
where people now choose these
prosthetic limbs based on who
they are and their
personality.
So if you're into, let's say,
motorcycles, you may get this
prosthetic limb, and it
may have chrome on it.
If you're into tattoos, you
may get your tattoo
replicated on there.
And what happens is, people's
behavior actually changes.
They no longer hide
their limbs.
They actually show them off.
They actually buy dresses
to match the prosthetic.
And this is sort of what we
think is paragon of this new
value creation economy that
we're seeing emerge out of
this volatility is someone--
entrepreneurs or large
businesses--
who really deeply understand
their customers on a very
deep, emotional, perhaps even
psychic level about the
customer's needs, and then
innovate both technologically
as well as in the actual
business model.
BRANT COOPER: So again, the
lean startup for the win--
fast, agile, tenacious, being
close to your customer,
continuously creating
new value.
So how do we do this?
The backdrop of this is what we
talk about in the book as
the innovation spectrum.
So if you've read Clayton
Christensen's "Innovator's
Dilemma," he uses the term
destructive technology on one
side, sustaining technology
on the other.
We believe this is
a continuum.
All companies live on
here somewhere.
PATRICK VLASKOVITS:
So like Brant
said, this is a continuum.
And there are distinct shades
of gray, but we're going to
contrast this with two
extreme poles.
So over here on the side, we
have sustaining innovation.
This is a car manufacturer,
automobile manufacturer coming
out with a new body
style, right?
So I have a 4Runner.
I think it's a 2006.
This is the 2008 4Runner--
incrementally better.
On some, it's got
a bigger engine.
It's more fuel efficient.
Perhaps it's lighter, right?
Or this is Gillette razors
coming out-- you've got 19
blades on your razor.
This year, it's got 27--
some incremental improvement.
What happens over here is,
generally speaking, the
problem's well understood, the
market's well understood, the
customers are well understood,
the sales and marketing
channels are well understood,
right?
Here, you have execution risk.
And here what we would say in
the way we look at the world,
traditional business methods
are sufficient, right?
So you can go and write
a business plan--
I'm going to now produce
a razor blade that has
35 blades on it.
And I'm going to sell to guys
like Reggie over here.
I know where they live.
I know how much money
they make.
I know why they like my razor
versus the Schick razor.
And you can go and execute
on that thing.
That's how we describe
sustaining innovation.
BRANT COOPER: So disruptive
innovation then is completely
turning a market
on its head, or
creating a brand new market.
Market's not understood.
It's not known--
problem unknown, solution
unknown.
New technology--
how do we apply it?
You go and you to talk
to your customers.
They actually don't
understand.
You can't believe what
they're going to say.
Over on this side, you
ask your customers,
would you buy this?
You cannot take their
answer to the bank.
Traditional business methods do
not work so well over here.
So Clayton Christensen, in
"Innovator's Dilemma," uses
hard drives as an example,
so tons of data
on hard drive companies.
Back in the '90s, five and a
quarter inch drives held 10
megabytes of data.
Companies would do
real innovation--
new materials, processes,
double the capacity, 20
megabyte hard drive.
Sustaining innovation.
Go out to your IT manager that
bought your 10 megabyte hard
drive, and you say, hey, you
want to double the capacity
here, same cost, maybe even
a little bit less?
Do you want it?
IT manager goes, yeah, of
course, that's awesome.
Great, when can I have it?
Oh, you'd pay $150?
Oh yeah, no problem,
got the budget.
You can actually build
great return on
investment cases here.
You know the market.
You know the customers.
You know how much they'll pay.
You can predict the success of
that company or that product
fairly well.
You've got competition.
You're fighting your
competition there?
Patrick likes to say over on
this side, you die because
your competitors have stabbed
you in the back, and they're
dancing on your grave.
Over here--
PATRICK VLASKOVITS: You're out
in the wilderness, die alone,
you starve to death, and nobody
even knew you existed.
BRANT COOPER: This
is traditionally
where startups live.
And your big businesses
do your sustaining
innovation very well.
Over on the startup side, you're
a new company and you
produce a three and
a half inch drive.
It holds 20 megabytes of data.
You go bring that same IT to
that same IT guy, that three
and a half inch drive, he thinks
it's a paperweight.
Has no idea what it's for.
Has no use for it.
So big businesses do
the sustaining
innovation very well.
It's not a pejorative.
This is where market share is.
It's where margins are.
It's where the large
market is.
This disruptive side
is all brand new.
You don't know if there's
a market there yet.
Most startups exist somewhere
in between.
Most startups really aren't
all the way over on the
disruptive side.
They're somewhere in between.
But the point really is that
the practices that you use
when you're experimenting or
you're interacting with your
customers differ based upon
where you are on the spectrum.
Over here, you can't believe
what the customers say.
Over there, eh, if you're really
over on the sustaining
side, you can understand.
You can believe what they say.
Over here, you're optimized
for learning.
On that side, you're optimized
for execution.
You've already learned how to
figure out products, features,
marketing, sales.
So there's actually some
things to think
about there, right?
I mean, in terms of human
resources, for example, over
here, you need people that are
willing to wear, like to wear
many hats, tend to like chaos.
Over on this side, they like
order-- in box and out box.
So we'll dive into that
a little bit more.
PATRICK VLASKOVITS: One thing
to note too is, I actually
have a theory on this
disruptive side.
If you're doing something really
disruptive, my theory
is that your sales and marketing
channels, you have
to actually innovate
on those, too.
So if you're doing something
fundamentally disruptive, and
you're taking best practices--
best practices are on
this side, right?
Best practices is sort of
execution-oriented risk, right?
But if you're doing something
crazy disruptive--
maybe like Google Glass,
for the example--
if you actually follow
sustaining innovation type
sales and marketing channels,
you're probably
not going to win.
BRANT COOPER: So how do you
disrupt inside of a large,
successful organization?
So this is the innovator's
dilemma.
Inside of most large
businesses,
innovation is a buzzword.
You can find it right
on their About page.
We are the most innovative
blah, blah, blah, blah.
You see it in their
advertisements, right?
The sustaining innovation
SUV that
Patrick was talking about--
I can't remember
what car it is.
It might be actually Mercedes
where the patents are flying
off of the car.
And this is the sign of their
innovation is how many patents
that they have.
And it's all on a vehicle that
is sort of marginally improved
from the year before.
So big business talks
about innovation.
But most big businesses, when
they're talking about
innovation, they're talking
about sustaining innovation.
They're talking about
incrementally improving
products, product lines, inside
of a known market.
And there's good
reason for it.
Again, margins are good,
market's are known.
So you can actually measure what
you think the return is
going to be on your endeavors.
So if you own the purse strings
inside of a large
organization and somebody comes
to you and says, hey,
I've got this great idea, here's
the market we're going
to sell to, here's what our
profit margin is, I think that
we should be able to get
this sort of return
within a couple years.
Versus the crazy startup guy
who goes, oh, I got this
really wacky idea, but he has
no idea what the market is,
whether he could sell to it.
If you're in charge of your
business unit, if you've got
the purse strings, which one
are you going to invest in?
Clearly, you're going to invest
rationally in the
existing market.
So that is the innovator's
dilemma.
Two questions that kill
disruptive innovation--
what's my ROI, and when
am I going to see it?
The only way you can answer that
question is to look at
existing markets.
So you're pulled over to
the sustaining side.
And we see this all across the
world when we're going and
talking to intrapreneurs--
entrepreneurs inside of these
large businesses.
They've actually been charged
with going out and doing quote
unquote "real innovation." And
yet, they come back, and their
business managers say, OK,
well what's the return on
investment?
It's the equivalent of writing
a business plan, which nobody
does in startups
anymore, right?
So back to that spectrum--
sustaining side, you can write
a business plan that's
believable.
Disruptive side--
business plans are just pulled
out of thin air, right?
Over on the sustaining side,
if you have your requisite
hockey stick revenues, it's
based on real data.
On the disruptive side--
completely made up.
It's like an inverse mullet.
Just draw it so it's business
in the front,
party in the back.
So we see this all over--
when is the ROI?
For traditional corporates,
when we're doing this in a
workshop, this is actually where
Patrick and I have to
pause, because on the opposite
side of the room, there'll be
a PM and her boss.
And they'll just sort of lean
across, and they'll start
talking to each other about the
mistake they made in terms
of these questions
being asked.
So how do we get beyond that?
Here are some of the typical
approaches to innovation.
You go hire Big Four, Big Five,
however many consulting
firms are left of
the big guys.
You go hire those guys,
and they talk about--
they come and they do rally.
Instead of Patrick and I
standing up here, it'll be a
management guru and will just
fire you up and inspire you to
go and be innovative, go be
internal visionaries.
Patrick and I's version
of that is
the myth of the visionary.
The other thing big businesses
do is they create these labs.
And they have these brilliant
people working in these labs
tinkering with new technology.
And yet, that technology never
sees the light of day.
Usually, it's because somebody
goes waltzing through there
and goes, oh yeah, that one's
good, meh, that's not so good.
Sort of this pick a
winner strategy.
And they take this technology,
and they throw it over the
transom to the core business.
And then they sort of wonder
why that product fails.
It doesn't work.
So then there's the management
team that sits around.
I've sat on this
management team
before in smaller companies.
And again, you sort of go, oh,
we're going to give $250,000
to this group, and nobody
else gets any.
They make this one big bet
on an internal startup.
And like most startups,
it's likely to fail.
And so there's their one shot,
and they go, oh god, this
stuff doesn't work.
Other ones try to turn core
business into a startup.
And that's a great way to
kill your core business.
And then finally, there's the
build a startup inside the
core business.
And so what we see here,
there's some benefits.
You get entrepreneurial spirit,
this culture of
experimentation, optimized for
learning, lots of chaos, Nerf
guns, super cool, right?
If you try to do this inside
of a large enterprise, then
you've got some problems.
Large businesses got
large because they
learned how to execute.
If you kill that because you
want to be startup-y, you're
killing where all your
money's coming from.
You can't just take a large
organization and
turn it into a startup.
You have brand issues.
You have legal issues,
regulatory issues, often.
You've got marketing people that
know how to market to a
particular segment.
You've got sales people that
need to earn their commissions
by selling their core
business products.
You start giving them these
startup products, and it
creates all sorts of
inefficiencies.
Nobody's smarter than sales
guys how to optimize their
commission, right?
So they start bundling their
products together, bundling
the new stuff with
the old stuff--
anything they can do in order
to earn their money.
We were talking to a big company
that actually does
some of this stuff
pretty well.
And an internal startup would
reach a certain level, and
they would throw their core
business support into the
startup world.
And suddenly, their whole
support organization gets
sucked into problems
that are emerging
with this new product.
So it's not just that the
startup has to be protected
from the big business.
The big business actually
has to be
protected from the startup.
So what we try to work with some
of these companies is,
how do you build this lean
startup mentality inside of a
large business?
You run multiple experiments,
not a pick a winner strategy.
You use validated learning to
measure the progress of these
companies instead
of just revenue.
We found that this one company,
in particular,
struggled with the whole
persevere or pivot.
And I thought it was
really interesting.
He said, management needs to
actually urge these internal
startups not to pivot.
They want to pivot too early.
The moment there's any trouble,
they want to pivot.
And actually, if you can flip
the motivations around so that
the management is actually
telling them to persevere,
that they saw bigger
wins that way.
But you have these different
stages inside of these
internal startups that are,
again, measured by validated
learning, not revenue, so
things like number of
passionate users, viral
coefficient, if that's important.
You start learning what the
lifetime value is, cost of
acquisition.
You're testing marketing
channels, testing innovation
of the marketing channels.
Then you have these stage two
internal startups where they
have to prove out their
business model.
What other market segments
can we go after?
Is it scalable?
And now you can start
looking at revenue.
But again, it's really about
the sustainability of this
startup and whether
it's scalable.
And you do all of these things,
which can take years
before you start migrating these
internal startups into
the core business.
PATRICK VLASKOVITS: Actually,
since we're at Google, we
should also talk about what I
think-- how Google, at least
up to now, sort of solves
this problem.
What I think happens here--
I'm not a Googler, so I don't
have any inner knowledge.
But what I think happens at
Google, actually, is that,
basically, these internal
experiments leave in the form
of folks leaving to start doing
their own startups, and
then they get acquired, right?
So when you get acquired, that's
your bonus for doing
something innovative, right?
If that works for Google,
that's fine.
I don't think that
works for a bunch
of other large companies.
Because actually, I think what
you can actually start doing
is start spawning competitors
very quickly.
So part of this message is
about how to create these
internal experiments, internal
startups, is to keep the
innovators in house, keep them
happy, and make sure to
incentivize them
the right way.
BRANT COOPER: Or even figuring
out what the application of
the technology is.
If it's just technology that's
being developed, then what is
the right product out
of that technology?
And the way the startup world
figures that out is actually
going and validating that
there's a product there.
Whereas if you just have
a lab's approach, they
typically--
in my experience, either the
technology never leaves the
lab, or if it leaves the lab,
it goes straight from lab to
core business.
And so somebody's actually
walking through the lab.
And based upon their own
visionary status, their
ability to predict
the future--
so it ends up that the managers
then are going, oh, I
know how to pick winners.
I'm the highest paid person in
the room, so I'm going to pick
which technology is a winner.
And then, I pluck it out, put
some money behind it, and go
throw it to the core business
without actually ever
validating whether there's a
market for that technology or
a market for that particular
application of technology.
Who's the right customer?
Who's their early adopter?
How do I market and how do
I sell to those people?
So that's my experience with the
traditional lab approach.
PATRICK VLASKOVITS: One pattern
we see quite often is,
when it gets kicked out of the
lab too early and it gets
kicked over to the sales folks,
like Brant mentioned
earlier, the sales folks
go, what is this?
I'm not sure.
Do my customers care?
They're focused on meeting their
target, making sales,
being the economic engine
of the organization.
And you've actually given them
another task now, right?
The difference between selling
something and discovering how
to sell something is
not trivial, right?
Does everyone know what
I'm talk about here?
There's a fundamental discovery
function that
happens on the disruptive side
and the execution on the
sustaining side.
And we see this over and over
again where great technology
shoots out of the lab, lands in
the saleswoman's lap, and
she's, again, tasked with
making sales, making
commissions, not discovering.
And then she'll do things like
bundle it with other products,
et cetera, et cetera,
et cetera--
anything to sort of get
it off the radar.
And then ultimately, the
product ends up dying.
AUDIENCE: So does that mean we
can have a lab, but we need to
have a separate execute
strategy for the lab?
BRANT COOPER: Right, so
organizations that have labs--
so we sort of have a three-stage
framework, which
is internal startup that's
proving customer passion.
Second stage is proving
the business model.
Third stage is the
core business.
Where there's labs, I just think
it's a fourth stage.
And that would be sort of stage
zero, which is the lab
is coming up with
new technology.
And then you need to find
somebody that wants to take
that idea and turn it into
an internal startup.
So you'd go from stage zero
to stage one then.
So there's nothing wrong
with the labs.
The problem has been
traditionally what we do with
the technology that's
inside the labs.
And super huge companies--
Xerox PARC, HP--
these are companies that had
brilliant technology that
never saw the light of day.
And really, my belief is--
I did a startup in the late '90s
that actually crashed at
the dot com crash, where we
took HP technology out of
their lab, and we were bringing
it to market.
And this is what
we would hear.
We did this tour of HP labs.
And there's scientists and these
brilliant engineers.
And they would sit there and go,
yeah, this kind of sucks.
None of our stuff ever sees
the light of day.
There was no method of getting
that stuff out.
So on the flip side--
protecting the core business
from the startup--
you need a set of ground
rules, right?
So sales and marketing are not
given these startup products.
Legal comes up with
ground rules.
So if you're a startup and
you want to do this
experimentation and you follow
these ground rules, then you
don't have to go to legal
to get approval.
This is huge, because the whole
idea in the startup
world is doing experimentation
fast.
So we've run across
these companies.
7-Eleven is a great example.
They actually brought
us in for lean
startup stuff, 7-Eleven.
They have an internal structure
responsible for
experimentation.
But it took five months to
get the results for one
experiment.
So imagine you're somebody
inside this large
organization.
You want to do something new,
you come up with an
experiment, give it to
this organization.
Five months later, you
get the result.
Like most results of
experiments, that first
iteration was a failure.
You're all like, eh,
I'm done with this.
I'm going back to my job.
You get five months
to get an answer.
So the whole point here is to
be able to put together
processes that allow you
to move quickly.
And one of those are, here's
the legal ground rules.
Here's the web terms of
service template.
If you use this, you don't
have to contact us.
There's all sorts of other
issues, though.
So I mentioned that startups
seem really super sexy.
So even if you're this
process-oriented person, you
go, oh, I'm going to go jump
into this startup.
That actually might
cause a problem.
So there's some HR issues that
need to be thought of.
I don't know if HR is
the right place for
them to come out of.
But it's important to
understand, who are the resources?
If you're in the chaos side, you
want people that thrive in
that sort of atmosphere versus
the people that thrive on the
execution side, on the
process-oriented side.
So support staff on core
products only--
how do you interact with
existing customers?
So this is a big issue for
a lot of big companies.
They don't want their startups
running experiments on their
millions of customers, right?
So how do you take a sliver of
those customers and run some
experiments?
Do you threaten the brand?
You go and you run an
experiment, and you're
throwing out in classic minimum
viable product.
You throw out some
crappy product.
It didn't quite reach viable.
You want that associated
with your brand?
Maybe not.
So you create a lab's brand, or
a fake brand, and really do
this experimentation under
this fake brand.
So there's all sorts of ways
that, if it's thought through,
the core business can actually
be protected from the startup.
PATRICK VLASKOVITS: And this
is something I think Google
has historically done
very well, right?
Google Labs has certainly had
a few really interesting
experimental products, right?
BRANT COOPER: So assuming one
buys all into this, and we're
going to build lean startups
inside of an organization, I'd
like to take a quick step back
and sort of give the
background on how our take
is on how this lean
startup stuff evolved.
So hopefully by now, we
all know that lean
does not mean cheap.
It doesn't mean small.
It doesn't mean don't spend
money or don't raise money.
Lean comes from lean
manufacturing, which describes
the way Toyota was building
cars in Japan in the '50s.
So lean is all about the
elimination of waste, right?
So in the manufacturing sense,
you had a known product, known
problem, known solution.
I'm building a car, maybe a
minivan for a soccer mom.
And so I have what's called
value add activities.
I'm actually assembling
the car.
And then I have not value add
activities, which might be,
I'm forklifting parts
from one side of the
warehouse to the other.
It doesn't actually contribute
to the value
that's being created.
So in lean manufacturing, what
you try to do is make as
efficient as possible the
value add activities and
eliminate as many of
the non-value add
activities as possible.
Some are necessary, but you
try to eliminate them.
So in lean manufacturing, there
are these concepts of
flow and pull, and basically
that's starting
with customer demand.
You only built parts and product
as the downstream
process demanded the part from
you or the process from you.
So it created this one piece
flow, so each car was actually
made in whole before the next,
all based upon demand, OK?
So that started eliminating
things like space required for
parts, for inventory.
Because you only made
what was demanded.
So that was a way that they
could then start eliminating
some of these non-value
add activities.
So in a lean startup, the
difference is, you don't
actually know the value
that you're creating.
And you don't know for whom.
So you think you know, right?
You have a business plan that
has documented all that you
think that you know.
But until the transaction
actually happens in the
marketplace, you don't truly
know, not until somebody has
paid you some sort of
currency for the
value that you're creating.
Now I know, right?
At least I'm starting
to begin to know.
So it sort of begs the question
though, if you don't
know the value that you're
creating, and you don't know
for whom, how do you know
what activities
are wasteful or not?
How do you know how to eliminate
non-value add
activities?
So Eric Reese talks about
validating learning.
So if you're not learning--
if you're in a state
of unknown--
if you're not learning,
you're wasting.
And so the lean startup would
try to use a set of principles
that allow us to learn,
continuously learn.
Now, it's important to
understand that once you
learn, then you execute,
right?
So this is the path from
sustaining innovation, or from
disruptive innovation
to sustaining.
You start out in a
state of unknown.
You're running experiments,
interacting with your
customers in a particular
way in order to
learn, in order to know.
And as you know, you execute
while continuing to learn
what's still unknown.
So people sort of get this stuck
in their head that they
always need to be creating
minimum viable products.
Well actually, once you've
learned what's viable, and
that there's a market
segment, now you've
got to start executing.
We're not always in MVP mode.
We're in MVP mode in order to
learn upon what to execute.
PATRICK VLASKOVITS: And in fact,
when we were talking
about the innovation spectrum,
if you're doing an MVP on the
sustaining side, you're
doing it wrong, right?
The context is there, the
market is there, the
customer's there.
All the things are known.
You don't want an MVP, you
actually want a whole product
over there, right?
So we've sometimes run into
stuff like, oh, I'm doing the
MVP, and basically, they're
ripping off some known
product, right?
MVPs aren't helpful.
MVPs are helpful as experiments
on the disruptive
side, right?
They're trying to actually
derive knowledge out of this
sort of unknown chaotic space.
BRANT COOPER: So the way we
help some startups, some
organizations large and small,
think through the learning
process is what we
call the value
stream discovery exercise.
So again, the value stream
is comprised of all the
activities that a business goes
through in order to make
a customer first aware,
all the way to
delivering the value.
And anything in between is the
discovery of the value.
So we have this model where we
look at seven states that a
customer goes through, emotional
states from a
buyer's perspective, from a
customer's perspective, the
states that they go through.
And then, what we look at are,
what are the four things we
can look at through
each state?
What does the company do to
get the customer to this
particular state?
What is the impact
on the customers?
So why do they believe they
are in this state?
Why are they feeling this way?
What action do I take
as a customer when I
achieve this state?
And how do I measure
that action?
And if one can discover that for
their whole product, then
what you've got is your growth
engine, minimum viable
product, this magic moment of
conversion where somebody is
willing to pay or maybe sign up,
the marketing funnel, and
then your acquisition
channels.
So you have a set of hypotheses
that cover what we
call the startup model.
So like Steve Blank likes to
say, startup is not a small
version of a big company.
So I like to say, well, a
startup doesn't need a
business model then.
A startup needs a
startup model.
And these are the
five components
of the startup model.
We've got a set of assumptions
now from aware to passionate.
And now we can go and try to
validate these and iterate on
them until we discover
each step.
When you're actually doing it
in practice, you start with
hopeful, satisfied,
and passionate.
So you may go out and get
tranches of users and test
your marketing as you get
tranches of users in order to
validate that you're actually
building something that
somebody wants, something
somebody needs or desires.
But you're not optimizing your
conversion, or your funnel, or
your acquisition until after
you've nailed passion.
So marketing--
your funnel, your
acquisition--
marketing is not about
creating buzz.
Marketing is amplifying
the buzz that
your product creates.
So people should already be
wanting to share your product.
They should be putting new
people into the top of your
funnel without spending
a dime on marketing.
That's when you know
you're ready to
start hitting the pedal.
So what we're hypothesizing
here-- what's the minimum
functionality that we need
to fulfill the promise?
So what is the promise you're
making to a customer segment,
fulfilling that minimally,
iterating on it until you have
what we consider a level of
satisfaction, which is a
hypothesis that you make.
A satisfied customer clicks on
features A, B, and C four
times a week.
That's a satisfied customer,
a hypothesis.
Measure that.
If you're not achieving it,
either you need to iterate on
the product, look at a different
market segment, or
change your hypothesis.
You're iterating on that until
you nail the satisfaction.
And then, what's the
difference between
satisfaction and passion?
So this is the money question.
And what's interesting is that
it can be outside the product.
Yep, you might be able to nail
the user experience--
the user experience is so
awesome that people are
passionate--
but it could be something
that's outside of it.
It could be, as Patrick
mentioned, that you've
innovated inside of the
marketing that creates
people's passion.
So HubSpot is a great example.
The people that share their
content the most are not
paying customers.
Their marketing itself
creates value.
And so they have this huge
constituency of people that
love HubSpot, even though they
can't afford the product.
Yet they're using the free
tools, they're sharing the
blogs, they're sharing the
e-books, and expanding the
market reach out to people that
actually can afford it.
Big brands are doing
this, right?
So brands that go green, or
brands that change their
packaging to make their
packaging more accessible, or
donating money to charities,
these are all ways that big
brands are trying to pull you in
to become passionate about
their particular brand.
Other ways it's separate.
I have this little survey
project that I'm doing.
And my customers are probably
only passionate about my
product when their business
succeeds.
Yet I can only help them so much
with my product, right?
They have to be a good
business person, too.
So what might I do to
induce passion?
Well, I might try to teach
them to become
better business people.
HubSpot actually does
this as well.
So if I can get them to grow
their business, then they'll
equate their success
with my product.
PATRICK VLASKOVITS: So in our
workshops, one of the examples
we like to use is--
I don't have it in my pocket
right now-- the American
Express Platinum Card
I actually have.
And I swear to god we're not
sponsored by American Express,
even though we should be.
BRANT COOPER: Here you go.
PATRICK VLASKOVITS: Oh, that's
the card right there.
So that card right there,
functionally, it's a credit
card like any other, right?
You swipe at the store, I get
the item, and then later on, I
pay my bill like it's
a credit card.
There are tens of thousands,
hundreds of thousands of
credit cards probably available
in the United
States, right?
Yet I love that card.
Why do I love that card?
Why do I use that card
exclusively when I travel?
The reason why is, they've
induced passion in me, because
it goes far beyond the
functionality of the product.
And this is something we talk
about in the book is, what am
I really hiring that
product to do?
What am I really hiring that
credit card to do?
I'm actually hiring it to solve
my vanity and security.
Because the reason I use that
credit card is it gets me into
airport lounges for free.
It makes me feel awesome.
That's what it does.
That credit card makes
me feel amazing.
It sounds sort of
goofy, right?
But that's exactly how you
get passionate users.
Functionally, it's a credit
card just like any other
credit card.
I'm going to belabor
this point.
But it makes you feel awesome,
so I can go to almost any
airport lounge.
And Brant and I do a lot of
traveling and speaking and
consulting.
And guess who gets to go,
walk in, flash his
card, and sit down?
It makes me feel awesome.
So what am I hiring
that product for?
I'm hiring it because apparently
I'm vain and
insecure and I need a--
BRANT COOPER: Affirmation.
PATRICK VLASKOVITS: Affirmation,
thank you.
I need affirmation of my--
BRANT COOPER: And how did you
learn about this card?
PATRICK VLASKOVITS: So how
did I learn about it?
Actually, you told me.
BRANT COOPER: Right, so I must
be vain and insecure as well.
PATRICK VLASKOVITS: Exactly.
The point is, this passion
stuff, it always goes much
deeper than pure
functionality.
Often, we talk to very
passionate founders.
And they're like, I built this
great product, does X, Y, Z.
And they're sort of stuck
at satisfied.
Oh, yeah, it does it.
So it's sort of like the
sandwich I had yesterday.
I had a sandwich, fine sandwich,
satisfied my hunger.
I got up and went
back to work.
Did I tell anyone about how
great the sandwich was?
No, it didn't meet this
really deep--
BRANT COOPER: You know, the
other great example I like to
differentiate is when we
went to Vancouver.
We're going and buying breakfast
before our talk.
And I chose the most
expensive thing.
It's just a little hole in
the wall breakfast place.
I chose the most expensive--
eggs, bacon, all this.
And it came with a small coffee,
which I thought was
really pretty odd.
And I'm all like, yeah,
can you just make
that a large coffee?
They were like, no.
I'm like, what?
Just make it a large coffee.
Oh, well we can substitute
this.
It'll cost you an extra $1.95
and blah, blah, blah.
And I'm all like, wow.
So I did it, bought
it, sat down.
It was OK.
And Patrick and I were
talking about this.
This is maybe the downside
of doing what we do.
We look at everything
through this lens.
But anyway, Patrick then told a
story of the evening before.
PATRICK VLASKOVITS: Yeah,
so we were at this
conference in Vancouver.
I'd actually gone to this
restaurant across the way.
I sat down by myself.
I was waiting for Brant to
arrive, or my wife to arrive.
Had dinner, ordered some
food, and then
I felt like a lemonade.
I'm like, hey, I don't see
lemonade on the menu.
Can I have a lemonade?
The waiter was like, we don't
have it on the menu, but I'll
make one just for you, right?
Guess who felt awesome?
This guy right here.
Guess who told everyone
about that restaurant?
By the way, it's called
Cardero's.
It's right on the pier
near Vancouver,
right near the Westin.
BRANT COOPER: And The breakfast
place that you
should avoid is right
across the street.
PATRICK VLASKOVITS: But so the
interesting thing actually--
real quick, let me go next.
But this stuff we're talking
about with the passion stuff,
I actually think some of the
best entrepreneurs in the
world, they think about
this stuff.
And they go way deeper than
functionality, right?
So the other day I was driving
home from Santa Barbara.
We were on the PCH in Malibu,
and we were stuck in traffic.
And we were right next to Nobu,
which is a very high-end
sushi chain, if you guys
are familiar with it.
And I was looking at Nobu.
I'm trying to figure
out, what are they
really selling, right?
I mean, superficially, they're
selling sushi, really good
sushi, theoretically.
But what are they
really selling?
And then I noticed, there's
two Ferraris.
And then, two guys who looked
like they owned the Ferraris
were sitting there talking.
I'm like, oh, I get it.
What they're really selling is,
if you're a high net worth
individual, here's where you
meet other high net worth
individuals, right?
That's what probably makes--
not only is it sushi grade,
but you see a birds
of a feather flock
together sort of thing.
BRANT COOPER: Did you
go eat there?
PATRICK VLASKOVITS:
No, I did not.
But the point is, this
passionate--
I like to think of myself
as a decent marketer.
And if you can imbue this,
figure out this passionate
part of the startup model, I
think you get really powerful
dividends on that.
Something most people I
think don't quite get.
BRANT COOPER: So we like to
look at this lean startup
stuff through the lenses
of understanding
your customer deeply--
how you interact with them,
how you run purpose built
experiments to test the
viability of your ideas, and
of course, measuring
the right data.
I'm guessing Google does
data pretty well.
So one of our most favorite
examples is AppFog.
Has anybody heard of AppFog?
So they're up in Portland.
So Lucas Carlson, the CEO, the
founder, is kind of a classic
hacker type, hangs out
on Hacker News.
He's always got several
projects going.
Never hit his home run though,
and he really wanted to.
He didn't want to just
be this hacker guy.
He actually wanted to build
a scalable business.
And he's a PHP programmer.
And a bunch of people were
chatting on Hacker News about
the need for these cloud
services, sort of
the Heroku for PHP.
Cloud services already existed
for Ruby, another development
language, and that was Heroku.
So people were talking on Hacker
News about the need for
these sorts of services
for PHP.
And Lucas says, OK, I'm
going to do it.
So it's late Friday night.
He's getting ready to start
coding like he always does,
just going to dive in.
It was kind of late.
His wife says, come to bed.
Work on that tomorrow.
And Lucas goes, all right.
So he puts up a classic Tim
Ferris-esque landing page, a
one page website.
Puts his messaging
positioning--
hey, you want to join
my beta program?
Click here.
Posts that on Hacker News
and goes to bed.
He wakes up the next day--
800 people signed up.
He's all like, wow, I got
something here maybe.
But I just promised these people
to enter a beta program
that doesn't exist.
So he starts coding, coding,
coding, coding.
A week goes by--
Two weeks go by, a month goes
by, and he's all like, if I
continue down this path building
this rock-solid cloud
services platform, it's going
to take six months, a year.
By this time, he's got 4,000
people signed up
for his beta program--
4,000.
So if it takes me a year,
what's going to happen?
I'm going to lose all
of these people.
So he decides to run what we
call a high hurdle experiment.
PATRICK VLASKOVITS: So this
was actually sort
of a stroke of genius.
He knew he couldn't support
all 4,000 people.
The product certainly
wasn't ready for it.
He didn't have time for it.
So what he needed to do is
actually surface who his early
adopters were, right?
And so typically what happens
in this case-- most startups
just open the gate and say,
we're open for business.
Come on in.
The stroke of genius was that
Lucas actually made them
surface themselves
by showing pay.
They actually had to trade
in some sort of currency.
And it wasn't money.
It was actually time.
So he developed a survey, an
open-ended, multi-question
survey with open text fields,
minimum 1,000 words, et
cetera, et cetera.
What's the meaning of life,
what's your favorite color?
Super open-ended stuff
that took you 45
minutes to get through.
So this wasn't a typical online
marketing thing where
it's like three questions, don't
ask them for their email
address, radio buttons and just
hit Submit, just where
you get high conversion rates,
but not very much fidelity or
detail on the data.
This is, if you want
access to AppFog--
BRANT COOPER: Jump through
this hoop.
PATRICK VLASKOVITS: --jump
through these hoops and these
four more hoops, right?
Because he wanted to whittle
down this group of 4,000 to a
few dozen, right?
What happened, cutting a long
story short, 50% of the people
converted on that survey,
to 2,000 people.
He actually then read
all 2,000 responses.
He also did some--
BRANT COOPER: Data mining.
PATRICK VLASKOVITS: --data
mining as well.
Turned out, the three things
that he thought were most
important were not.
Long story short, he's seeing
exponential black swan-like
type growth.
He's doing really great, ended
up raising something like $10
million last year.
They're growing steadily.
The point is really, though,
what he needed to do right--
he did a lot of things right--
but he surfaced.
He actually made these early
adopters pay for
the product, right?
So people who aren't going to
pay with their time aren't
probably going to be good
early adopters for this.
BRANT COOPER: So I love also
that he did market
segmentation really there.
The fact is, he knew where
his market hung out.
He was one of them, but he
didn't just listen to himself.
He went out, and there was all
these people on Hacker News.
So that was actually
good marketing.
He didn't necessarily just
believe-- a lot of startups,
oh, I got thousands of email
addresses, and they go, oh
yeah, I'm good to go.
A bunch of people gave me
their email address.
But he didn't believe that.
He doubled down and really made
these people prove that
they actually wanted
his product.
And then what he built
was a classic
minimum viable product.
He actually, instead of building
the rock solid
platform based on the data
that he gathered--
just three or four features.
Imagine three or four features
on the user interface.
What is the minimum I need to do
to fulfill the promise I've
made to these people?
Put that on the user interface,
and then just build
the back end for those three or
four features, and launch.
It's funny, I was telling this
story at my coffee meet up
down in San Diego.
And three or four of the people
in the coffee meet up
went, oh, I remember that.
I was on that.
God, that product sucked.
And it was like, yeah,
but did you use it?
Oh yeah, it was the only
thing available, right?
So it gave him the platform, it
gave him the start of where
to iterate on.
What was his launching point?
What is this minimum
viable product?
And that's what he
built a whole
scalable company around--
a fascinating story.
Good, well that's what
we got for you.
So we'd love to hear more about
what's going on at Google.
[APPLUASE]
BRANT COOPER: So anybody have
some good stories here, or
issues that Google's facing,
or what you guys do well?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Question--
how do you guys really think
about [INAUDIBLE]
setting up tests around--
BRANT COOPER: Like for
internal processes?
AUDIENCE: Internal processes
or teams, and just--
BRANT COOPER: Yeah, well it's
an interesting question.
Yeah, well I think that you're
almost talking what I'm
calling the stage two.
If they graduate from stage two
and a particular product
has proved its business model,
instead of turning that over
to a core business, you just let
it continue to function.
Let it grow organically into
a core business of its own.
PATRICK VLASKOVITS: I think what
you're saying is, I think
that the way that problem gets
solved in the startup world--
I don't know about the
large org world--
you have cross-functional teams
that sort of naturally
mutate to the right response
to the market.
Does that make sense?
And actually, we talk about
cross-functional teams.
I think with the way that
product management and product
development is changing,
because of this sort of
hyper-connected software economy
we're living in, I
think you're going to see what
you're talking about.
Instead of these functional
lines of business-- like,
marketing, hand it over
to sales, and
you have these siloed--
I think you're going to see, in
some cases, more of these
cross-functional teams that
basically mutate to the proper
market response.
Does that make sense?
No.
AUDIENCE: Kind of--
I mean, you're always going
to have front-line sales
[INAUDIBLE], right?
A large company like this will
always have [INAUDIBLE]
most of our money.
You're always going to have--
BRANT COOPER: Doing a completely
different selling
model versus what the core
business is doing.
AUDIENCE: Exactly.
BRANT COOPER: Yeah, I don't
think I actually can come up
with examples.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
one guy who's like a quarterback
[INAUDIBLE]
product specialist
[INAUDIBLE].
BRANT COOPER: I've seen it
around market segments.
Intuit's acquisition of Mint was
really going way outside
of their comfort zone, because
they had no ability to market
and attract that particular
constituency.
But also, they did already
have online sales.
So it's not like
they completely
changed their sales model.
So yeah, I'm not sure.
I think that there's a natural
growth where organizations
start online.
And then they evolved to field
sales, or vice versa, so that
they're covering different
channels.
But I think it's driven by
market segments more than it
is by concentrating on specific
selling models.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
BRANT COOPER: Right, so your
market segment is actually--
this is one of our problems,
actually, with some of the
business model canvas stuff is
that it presumes that you're
making decisions about your
market segmentation and your
sales channels and your
marketing and your partners
sort of independently.
And actually, your market
segment drives all of that
stuff, right?
So if you choose a particular
market segment, they expect to
buy in a particular way.
And so if you chose field
sales and you're doing a
segment that expects online
sales, then you've got a
fundamental mismatch.
PATRICK VLASKOVITS: The esoteric
analog idea I like to
use is, you're playing
a game of
simultaneous equations, right?
Your market segment channels
your product, right?
Those are all independent
variables that you actually
have to solve for at the same
time, simultaneously.
And if you do that
right, you have a
scalable business, right?
And if you double down-- let's
say you hold one constant,
then you have to make sure
the others fit, right?
And so what you're saying is,
you should let the sales
channel flip.
You should be able to flip
that variable and let the
others solve for that, right?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PATRICK VLASKOVITS: How to
change the sales model?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PATRICK VLASKOVITS: You know,
some of the most interesting
people that do some of this
stuff are the mercenary
affiliate marketers and direct
marketer staff, the guys that
actually buy a lot of--
they have big PPC spends.
Those guys are pretty aggressive
in experimentation.
They almost don't care what
they sell as long
as they make money.
I have friends in that space.
And they often are very open to
experimenting in terms of
sales models, often because
their concern is their sale
spend, right?
That's sort of the driving
concern for those people.
But I've seen those people
do sort of small-scale
experiments.
Those are generally not
very large businesses.
BRANT COOPER: I think most of
the examples I can think of
off the top of my head come
from acquisition.
And so they're acquiring
somebody that has a different
sales model.
And the question then becomes,
do they try to suck it in, or
do they let it go, let it
continue to just be what made
that company successful and why
they wanted to acquire it?
But I can't think of, off the
top of my head, a large
organization that's running
experiments around changing a
sales model.
But I don't see why--
I think part of the lean startup
stuff gets stuck
inside of engineering
departments.
And there's just really no
reason why it can't be started
over in marketing
or sales or PM.
I think it's really the concept
of allowing people to
take a percentage of their time
and do whatever they want
should be across the board,
all functions.
And then having individuals
like that--
the ability to go out
and run their own
experiments like that.
Yeah, so it depends on
what the product is.
So the stage one--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
BRANT COOPER: Right, so it's
all based upon your
hypotheses.
So everything you're doing
is just starting with a
hypothesis.
If I do X, customers will do
Y, or a Y percentage of
customers will do Z.
PATRICK VLASKOVITS: So if the
experiment fails, that you
know why it failed, right?
If you don't know why it failed,
it's like, oh, that
didn't work, you'd much prefer,
oh, that didn't work
because it turns out
my customers
don't like blue lollipops.
It turns out they actually
hate them because it
reminds them of--
I don't know what, right?
That's actually-- you've
learned something.
And then, you can actually
build up this body of
knowledge and theoretically
pivot to
something that works, right?
But it's actually an interesting
question, because
one of the large companies we
work with, they have these
intrapreneurs--
we've talked about that.
You can actually go through a
cycle of learning tremendous
amounts, and the actual
project fails.
And right now, the structures
and processes are set up like,
oh, your projects failed, ergo
you've not performed well.
But they've actually created a
body of knowledge around this.
And that actually has
created value.
BRANT COOPER: That's really
where the true meaning of the
word "pivot" comes from is, if
that thing fails, yet there's
learning in there that actually
forms the basis of a
new project.
But again, if you're making a
promise to somebody, what's
the minimum functionality that's
going to fulfill that
promise becomes your minimum
viable product.
Then you should be able to
create a hypothesis that says,
this is what people are going
to do will indicate
satisfaction.
And so in the different various
startup stages, the
validating learning that you're
using could be number
of customers that
have indicated
that they're passion.
I'm seeing a viral coefficient
of 0.7.
I've got 1,000 customers
within this
specific market segment.
So it's measuring user passion,
and then it's
measuring the number of users
based upon what you think you
should be seeing.
And then it starts getting into,
well, how much does it
cost for me to acquire them?
And what's the lifetime value?
And can I shrink the sales
cycle that increases the
velocity of customer passion?
And so these are the things
that you want to--
and this stuff only really works
when you have buy-in
from the top.
Because there are all of these
metrics that you have to prove
before profitability.
But the moment you measure
profitability first, then
that's almost a guarantee
of failure.
Because it's less popular than a
black swan that somebody can
stumble across some new
disruptive that starts
producing money quickly.
So does that answer at all what
you're trying to get at?
PATRICK VLASKOVITS: It's always
contextual, right?
So let's say I had a community
site with user-generated
content, right?
An appropriate metric might be
time spent on site, or balance
rate, or what have you.
Because I could say, hey Brant,
looks like I had 10,000
visitors, and on average they
spent 25 minutes per day.
I know that's pretty good.
Something's happening.
I haven't made any money
on these guys yet.
But the fact anyone is spending
25 minutes on my
site, that's actually
nontrivial.
Let's dig in further, right?
BRANT COOPER: Yep.
AUDIENCE: Hi Patrick, Brant,
thanks for being here.
BRANT COOPER: You're welcome.
AUDIENCE: So the question I have
is around selecting the
market segment.
So say I have an MVP, I did
whatever serving thing
[INAUDIBLE].
PATRICK VLASKOVITS: What's your
objective in terms of that?
AUDIENCE: So I can go deeper and
find more of those people.
BRANT COOPER: So yeah, we didn't
really touch on market
segments at all.
But basically, the first thing
we usually talk about is that
market segment's defined by
people that share the same
problem or passion.
So it's not demographics.
It's not, I'm going after
a particular vertical or
firmographics.
People who share the same pain
or passion and speak the same
language, which means that they
would refer to each other
for solutions.
So if you're going out there
and you're running these
purposeful experiments to test
these different market
segments, then we talk about in
the book just a simple back
of the napkin approach of
using a segment matrix.
So you can list your different
market segments based on rows.
And then, your columns are
different ways to evaluate
those market segments-- could be
depth of pain, how easy are
they to reach in terms of
marketing, do they have budget
if that's necessary, how easy is
it to build an MVP for this
particular market segment, or
even, what are your particular
personal values or
corporate values?
Here's a market segment that's
important to us.
Here's one, eh, it's not
that important to us.
Rank them all high, medium, and
low inside of this matrix,
go out and validate that your
estimations are about right.
Usually one or two market
segments sort of rises to the
top as ones that, based on your
own evaluation, look like
they would be the right market
segments to go after.
Sometimes I counsel you might
do like a 70-20-10 approach.
Put 70% of your resources into
the top segment, 20% into a
second segment, let the
rest be opportunistic.
Go out and try to validate
whether this is going to be a
winning segment.
And if not, you've got the
second one that's sort of
already in motion.
And you've got the 10%
opportunistic that you can
raise up to being the
second one again.
So that might be one approach.
PATRICK VLASKOVITS: In the book,
we talk about the jobs
to be done model, which
is something--
AUDIENCE: The what?
PATRICK VLASKOVITS: Jobs to be
done model of segmentation.
Clayton Christensen and his
colleagues developed that.
And it's, what are you hiring
the product for?
So the classic example is, as a
customer, if I buy a quarter
inch drill bit, what am I
really buying, right?
I'm buying a quarter
inch hole, right?
And so you look at segmentation
through that model.
What's the problem that
you're solving?
And that is actually
very insightful.
We talk about that
in the book, too.
Well, thank you.
Thanks for having us.
BRANT COOPER: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]